welcome um can you all hear me okay
great okay so today we're gonna be
talking about algorithms for DNA data
storage I'm Ruthie Ngoc Manny I'm a
software engineer based in New York City
and that's my twitter handle if you have
any questions about DNA data storage
feel free to tweet at me
[Applause]
[Music]
so in 2016 Microsoft set a new record
for the amount of data written to DNA
they encoded and stored thirty five
distinct files totaling two hundred
megabytes of data using about two
billion nucleotides or DNA base pairs in
total these files included this - she'll
pass by okay go which we just watched a
clip of the Universal Declaration of
Human Rights in over a hundred languages
the top 100 books from Project Gutenberg
and a crop trust database of all the
seeds stored in the Svalbard global Seed
Vault and see one second and it was
about this big
DNA is one of the most efficient forms
of data storage we know of which is
important because we are producing so
much data 2.5 quintillion bytes of data
are being created or captured each day
90% of the data on the internet was
created since 2016 and in division all
the digital data were producing we're
also starting to capture a lot of
scientific data at a scale we've never
done before
the Sloan Digital Sky Survey produces
73,000 gigabytes of data per year the
Large Hadron Collider generates 50
million gigabytes of data per year in
the next 10 years researchers
researchers estimate that have 40
billion gigabytes of genomic data are
going to be stored and we're going to
store them for decades for regulatory
reasons and a billion people are
predicted to have their genomes
sequenced by 2025 so a lot of data and
we're starting to run out of ways to
store that data we are approaching the 1
terabyte per square inch capacity of
hard disk drives past this point
temperature fluctuations can induce data
corruption we could use more heat
resistant material with us this would
require major shifts in our storage
infrastructure and a lot of associated
costs we also have challenges to current
storage
systems like magnetic tape is an
attrition rate of 22 percent and only
lasts between five and ten years we have
to keep rewriting data to it and just to
give you a sense of the scale we're
talking about the Large Hadron Collider
that I talked about in the last example
stores those 15 million gigabytes of
data on a distributed grid of over 130
thousand CPUs 230 million gigabytes of
magnetic tape storage and 300 million
gigabytes of online disk storage so a
lot of data is starting to run out of
ways to store that and DNA might be the
solution so DNA what even so some people
refer to DNA is the code of life it's
basically you know what gives their body
instructions and what proteins to make
what genes to turn on and off just as a
review so there's four base pairs
eighty-ninth imine cytosine and guanine
a and T at a ninth I mind bind to each
other's C and G sigh design and Guana
and bind to each other some of the bonds
are stronger some are weaker that's what
cause that's what causes the double
helix shape there's a phosphate backbone
and what you really need to know for the
purposes of this talk is that there's
four base pairs a T C and G and if
you're thinking about storing data in
DNA you're translating data in some way
to those base pairs so what makes DNA
data storage so exciting
density DNA has an ultra high storage
density as much as a hundred trillion
gigabytes per gram it's 107 times denser
than magnetic tape compactness I
remember the image of the DNA and a tip
of a pencil it's an extremely compact
form of data storage resilience DNA
doesn't have to be powered by an
external energy source to retain data as
long as it's stored in a controlled
environment DNA can survive in less than
ideal conditions for hundreds of
thousands of years we've recovered DNA
from over 800,000 years ago it also
doesn't require active maintenance or
rewriting every so often redundancy and
replication are built-in features in DNA
interoperability obviously DNA has been
around for a while and it will continue
to be around for a lot longer so that's
part of why we're really excited about
DNA is a data storage
mechanism but it's also challenging for
a variety of reasons cost synthesis or
creating and writing DNA and sequencing
or reading DNA is still expensive and
its cost prohibitive compared to
existing forms of data storage like
beyond kind of experiments and so on
speed the speed of reading and writing
data to DNA is not comparable to digital
storage sequencing DNA sequencing can
miss read long strands of the same base
so that's a challenge the researchers
have been working through data loss data
corruption DNA especially in a living
organism will mutate with insertions
deletions and so on a lot of these
examples are using synthetic DNA so
there's less vs. like DNA in a living
cells so it happens less often but in
all cases you know there are gonna be
mutations or you know data lost with
sequencing and rewriting and with
replication these can get amplified
corruption can also happen if the DNA is
not stored correctly search how can we
find something specific without having
to sequence all the DNA capacity what's
the maximum we can successfully write to
DNA and have it be retrieved correctly
so the question researchers have been
exploring the molecular structure
sequences containing a lot of the G
nucleotide for example are difficult to
write because they often produce
secondary structures that interfere with
synthesis and so to solve all these
problems there's kind of requires an
interdisciplinary approach that combines
information theory coding Theory
computer science compression algorithms
then I also add a deep understanding of
molecular biology synthetic biology
chemistry you know physical computing
industrial engineering for the devices
that are doing the sequencing and doing
the reading and doing the writing of
date of DNA data to DNA so it's kind of
this really exciting the
interdisciplinary field or just part of
why I'm excited to share it with you
today so now we're going to talk about
some of the milestones how we got to
where we are today and where the field
is going next
so um in 1977 the first DNA genome was
sequenced read it was sequenced in a
Frederick Sanger lab you can see a
picture of him there
they sequence the virus 5x 175 a
bacteriophage found in e.coli how do we
start to explore the idea that DNA could
hold a message in 1979 Japanese
researchers hiromitsu Yoko and Tyra
Oshima asked whether the DNA sequence by
Sanger might hold a message encoded by
extraterrestrial life you can see an
article from the New York Times at the
time scientists examined tiny viruses
for messages from outer space it's a
really fun read and if you have a time
subscription would recommend checking it
out and they weren't the first people to
propose that either in 1973 dr. Francis
Crick proposed a theory of directed
panspermia that alien civilizations may
have put messages in DNA to disperse the
seeds of life throughout the universe so
this was kind of exploring the idea does
DNA hold a message could DNA hold a
message the first time messages were
stored in DNA was in 1988 you can see
here a piece
it's called micropenis it was done by
the artist Joe Davis in collaboration
with the molecular biologist Dana Boyd
they took this ancient Germanic rune
that's in yellow that represents life in
the female Earth and since this design
they encode it into a bitmap image you
can see that over there and then design
and synthesized that into a 18 base pair
message and put that into e.coli
creating a living work of art since then
here are some of the things that have
been stored in DNA you can see a poster
of Citizen Kane smiley face emoji
computer operating system early silent
films books about synthetic biology da
vinci mary had a little lamb I have a
dream Amazon giftcards
Claude Claude Shannon's information
theory Malloy bridges famous photography
sequence and obviously bitcoin so in
2001 you know was the first example of
naive encoding and translating and so
what they did was basically translate
each letter of the alphabet into a
combination of DNA base pairs a team of
researchers at Mount Sinai School of
Medicine wrote to Dickens quotes into
DNA it was the best of times it was the
worst of times it was the age of wisdom
it was the age of foolishness this
totalled seventy bytes and DNA sequences
so basically they translated each letter
of the alphabet as a combination of the
bases a C and T so a a a would be the
letter a a a C would be the letter B and
so on so fast forward eight years of
2009 researchers introduced Huffman
coding to kind of make DNA storage of
data and DNA more efficient so
researchers at the University of Toronto
encoded more than 200 bytes of text
music and an image from the nursery
rhyme mary had a little lamb into DNA
can see some of that here to do this
they utilized Huffman coding a lossless
data compression algorithm where he
basically assigned variable length codes
to input characters and the lengths of
the assigned codes are based on the
frequencies of the correspondent
characters so the more most frequent
character gets the smallest code and the
least frequent character it gets the
largest code this allowed them to
utilize base assignment to enable
efficient coding of characters in 2010
2012 researchers scaled up the amount of
data written to DNA and this kind of
helped prove that storing data at scale
and DNA could be very dense and accurate
as there are two main examples here in
August 2012 the journal science
published research by George Church
shreeka Surrey
and colleagues at Harvard University in
which DNA was encoded with digital
information that included an HTML draft
of churches 53,000 400 word book
Regenesis how synthetic biology will
reinvent nature in ourselves 11 JPEG
images and this is my favorite part a
JavaScript program that displays DNA
that can curve dynamically to follow the
cursor I looked really hard to find the
JavaScript program could not find it in
any of their supporting materials but
I'm continuing to look so follow up with
me um in this work the aim to illustrate
the DNA like digital media can encode
executive all directives for digital
machines multiple copies for redundancy
were added they developed a strategy
that eliminated the need for long
sequences which were more likely to be
misread by sequencers instead they
encoded data and distinct blocks and
store these in shorter separate
stretches kind of analogous to storing
data on a hard drive in discrete sectors
they encoded one bit for every base
pairs
encoding a or C a0 and G or G is 1 so
about half of the theoretical maximum
which would be two bits in total a team
made fifty four thousand eight hundred
and ninety eight oligonucleotides or
stretches of DNA each including ninety
six base pairs of data along with the
twenty two base sequence at each end to
allow the fragments to be copied in
parallel and a unique nineteen base
address sequence marking the segment's
position in the original document the
resulting DNA held about six hundred and
fifty kilobytes of data in such a
compact form that the team predicted
storage potential for their method of
more than seven hundred terabytes per
cubic millimeter so this result
represented a significantly larger
volume of data than had previously been
artificially encoded in DNA and it also
showcased a data density for DNA several
orders of magnitude greater than that of
state-of-the-art electronic storage
media at the time so you can kind of see
that here shortly after in January 2013
nature published research from Nick
Goldman at the European bioinformatics
Institute were over five million bits of
data was stored retrieved and reproduced
including all 154 of Shakespeare's
sonnets included one here a classic
scientific paper molecular structure of
nucleic acids by James Watson Watson no
Francis Crick a medium resolution color
photograph of the European
bioinformatics Institute a twenty six
second excerpt from Martin Luther King's
1963 I have a dream speech and a Huffman
code used in this study to encode data
and importantly all the DNA files were
produced the information at 100%
accuracy so the main innovations in this
research were the use of an
error-correcting encoding scheme to
ensure the extremely low data loss rate
as well as the idea of encoding the data
in a series of overlapping short chunks
identifiable through a sequence based
indexing scheme the sequences of the
individual strands of DNA overlapped in
such a way that each region of data was
repeated four times to avoid errors two
of the four strands were constructed
backwards also with the goal of
eliminating errors to ensure the no base
was used twice in a row the digit that
each DNA base encoded depended on the
nucleotide that immediately preceded it
so for example a C and G were assigned
to represent zero one and two at the
nucleotide immediately after a T but
following an A the digits 0 1 & 2 are
encoded as a CG T
so this strategy basically helped avoid
the creation of any long stretches of
the same base again bad for sequencing
while still making use of DNA's for base
potential and so in this work the cost
for megabytes were estimated at twelve
thousand four hundred to encode data two
hundred and twenty dollars for retrieval
and they predicted cost-competitive sub
50 or archival storage in DNA within a
decade in twenty fifteen reed-solomon
error codes were introduced into DNA so
this is kind of like a tried and true
error correction method that is used
across a lot of different mediums and it
was a big step forward when I was
brought into DNA and basically every
research work since then utilizes this
so in February 2015 researchers from
Zurich reported perfect retrieval of 83
kilobytes of data in DNA so the
innovation they did was adding
redundancy via the reed-solomon error
correction codes which are using
consumer technology data transmission
broadcast systems and more so basically
provided a signal processing technique
for repairing corrupted messages in DNA
in 2015 random access was introduced
into DNA which basically meant that
instead of having to sequence all of the
DNA and then translate it back whatever
algorithm you use to translate your data
into DNA translating it back and then
find what you wanted you could like to
search for that exact piece of
information so that's a major step
forward in terms of getting to parity
with other forms of storage systems so
in September 2015 a researcher named
Olga chameleon Kovac and her lab at the
University of Illinois introduced random
access and easily rewritable DNA based
storage architecture this was based on
DNA sequences of specialized in address
strings that could be used for selective
information access it basically it
overcame drawbacks of existing read-only
methods are required decoding the whole
file in order to read one DNA fragment
and as a proof-of-concept they encoded
parts of the Wikipedia pages of six
universities in the US and selected and
edited parts of the text written DNA
corresponding to three of these schools
and in February 2018 Microsoft built on
this work
announced they'd achieved random access
in large-scale DNA storage so having a
much you know larger scale of data that
had previously been done they
selectively amplified specific sequences
from a DNA sample of more than 10
million oligonucleotides or stretches of
DNA and they created a library of
primers that were attached to each DNA
sequence the primers were used as
targets to select desired snippets of
DNA through random access before
synthesizing the DNA containing data
from a file
the researchers appended both ends of
each DNA sequence with primer targets
from the primer library and 2016 we
talked about this earlier but Microsoft
had shaved a record amount of data
stored in DNA so again like kind of
moving from these like theoretical ideas
to proof of concept and they also
announced a goal operationalizing DNA's
data storage by 2020 in 2017 the DNA
fountain method was introduced and it
dramatically you know enhanced the
information density capacity of DNA and
so yeah it's a allowed DNA to reach 85%
of its Shannon capacity so the
researchers are working this renamed
yani of early and Dena szalinski there
at Columbia University in the New York
genome Center and DNA the method they
developed they call it DNA found in it
stores data at a density of 215
petabytes per gram of DNA and just to
give you a sense of that scale one
petabyte is equivalent to thirteen point
three years worth of HD video the
technique approached a theoretical
maximum capacity or Shannon capacity of
DNA storage and Shannon capacity is
named after the information theorist
Claude Shannon it defines the notion of
channel capacity or the upper bound in
which information can be reliably
transmitted over a communication channel
their encoding method achieved 60% a 60%
increase in storage capacity over
previously reported efforts and so
basically the way they did this is they
started with two basic principles one
and not all DNA molecules are created
equally like you don't want long
stretches of the same base pair - not
all DNA molecules are going to make it
there's gonna be your noise and you know
errors and so on so handling that and so
their encoder works and three basic
steps first of pre processes a binary
file into a series of non-overlapping
segments of a certain
then they use this thing called the
Looby transform which is a relatively
recent addition to coding theory that
sets the basis for fountain codes which
are used in a variety of communication
standards and so what it does is it
packages the data into short messages
they call droplets which are transmitted
over a noisy channel a user can recover
a file by collecting a subset of
droplets as long as the accumulated size
of the droplets is slightly bigger than
the size of the original file the
droplet contains two pieces of
information a data payload and a short
fixed length seed the seed corresponds
to the state of a random number
generator and it allows the decoder
algorithm to infer the identities of the
segments in the droplet and then they
screen the droplets kind of make sure
that it has you know an ideal set of DNA
sequence or base pair sequences that
there won't be an issue it's like you
know see reading it or so on or like too
many G's or whatever so they screen the
droplets and if it doesn't pass a test
you just trash it and make another
droplet so it keeps iterating over
droplet creation and screening until a
sufficient number of droplets are
created and then yeah once they they
recover the droplet by mapping the read
to its original binary format they
reject droplets with errors based on the
reed-solomon codes and they employ a
message passing algorithm to reverse the
Looby transform and obtain the original
data so beyond kind of proving that we
can get to this really high level of
information density in DNA it can also
reduce the amount of sequencing required
for data retrieval so one of the caveats
of DNA data storage is that previous to
DNA fountain each retrieval information
would consume a portion of the material
and so while it's possible to copy the
data it also introduced noise and so
with this you can do a deep copy and it
doesn't introduce the noise so
theoretically you can copy data
virtually unlimited number of times and
preserve the data integrity in full and
so this is what people saw when they
decoded the data and this is a movie
called the arrival of the train at La
Ciotat it's one of the first silent
films and basically when people saw this
movie in theaters they ran away because
they thought it was a real train coming
towards them
there's a computer operating system
DaVinci drawings I think and then Claude
Shannon's information theory treatise in
2017
DARPA started the molecular informatics
program which basically seeks a new
paradigm for data storage retrieval and
processing instead of relying on binary
digital logic you know von Neumann
architecture molecular informatics sort
seeks to investigate and exploit the
wide range of structural characteristics
and properties of molecules to encode
and manipulate data and so to date
they've given now over fifteen point
three million in grants so you know one
of the big challenges with a DNA data
storage and kind of bringing it closer
to parity with other forms of storage is
cost and so in 2017 we started to have
cheaper sequencers called nanopore
sequencers but they're also you know
much more error-prone and they're
error-prone in different ways than
traditional more expensive and more
accurate sequencers and so in 2017 the
researcher who worked in the random
access product project Merlin Kovac she
published research that basically
devised error correcting algorithms
specifically aligned with the kinds of
errors of these sequencers make you can
see this is kind of what they wrote
Citizen Kane poster and the smiley face
emoji and then this is like what
originally came back and this like after
their error correcting algorithms you
can see it was recovered fully
so they achieved the error tolerance via
consensus sequence construction
algorithms and asymmetric deletion
correcting codes that were you know
tailor-made for this kind of sequencer
and the consensus method they used
combines multiple sequence alignment
methods and site information provided by
the address sequences of the DNA
segments and the deletion correcting
codes they used were designed for errors
that occur in these consensus sequences
in 2017 was a really exciting
application for DNA data storage
recording biological interactions in DNA
or some people call it molecular
ticker-tape
so in July 2017 researchers at George
church's lab at Harvard published
research exploring how DNA could
function as a biological recording
device by using CRISPR class 9 so Chris
podcast 9 is a molecular tool that
combines special proteins and RNA
molecules to precisely cut an edit DNA
during a viral invasion and the proteins
go out and grab a piece of the attackers
DNA and they store those in clustered
regularly interspaced short palindromic
syndromes which is what CRISPR stands
for so usually like you know
traditionally in a Cell these are used
to recognize and deactivate a virus next
time it attacks but people have been
using this technique to kind of do a
more precise form of gene editing like
choosing what you snip choosing what you
put in and kind of using that on purpose
so anyway cat sign is the protein that
does the cutting and cast one in two
proteins tell TAS nine where to do the
cutting and they don't just you know
insert viral DNA and at random they
actually put it in in the order in which
it arrives and so that can turn the
genome into a temporal record of
whatever happens in a Cell so you can
see how they tested that out they
encoded this famous a chip of a famous
photography sequence of a horse
galloping by the photographer Eadweard
Muybridge into the genomes of a
population of living ecoli bacteria they
were able to retrieve and reconstruct
the images with 90% accuracy storing
data in living cells is also an
interesting innovation here most
features research stores data and
synthetic DNA which is more stable and
reliable but it's more on for so it's
more unpredictable and more prone to
mutations when you store data and living
cells but there's also some really
exciting applications there in 2018
image search was introduced into DNA a
team at the University of Washington led
by Louis says they launched a social
media campaign to collect 10,000 images
to be stored in DNA this is the site
they launched hash tag memories in DNA
and so people could submit photos and
they aim to develop a search by image
feature in DNA making molecules carryout
computer vision work to extract
identifying features like color texture
and shape so basically you know if you
think like chemistry offers a palette of
molecular diversity like structure size
charged in polarity that can be
harnessed for information processing and
says his lab extracted visual features
from the crowdsource images and then map
them onto DNA so each photo might get
tens of thousands of unique DNA segments
one encoding for a pair of a vertical
line or patch of blue and then his lab
introduced a coded query containing
complementary DNA base pairs
corresponding to these visual features
so each query sequence would get a
special coating of magnetic
nanoparticles that could indicate all
the sequences that were a match and only
these sequences would be selected
extracted and translated back into
visual images you can see some of the
images that were submitted here in 2018
a company called catalog announced this
innovative thing called the library
approach and basically what they do is
they use prefabricated strands of DNA to
write to reduce the cost of writing DNA
versus synthesizing DNA base pair by
base pair so generally like a lot of the
cost savings in the last year's have
been around sequencing DNA but the cost
of writing DNA are still quite
prohibitive so like for example like
there's a synthesis company called twist
bioscience the charges between 7 and 9
cents per base so you know if you
translate that into a single minute of
high quality stereo sounds that's stored
for about $100,000 so not really
competitive today but in 2016 to give
you another example in 2016 when
Microsoft set a record by storing the
200 megabytes of data in DNA they used
13 million four hundred and forty eight
thousand three hasn't three hundred and
seventy two unique pieces of DNA so
comparing that to catalog what catalog
does is they generate large quantities
have a few different DNA molecules like
20 to 30 base pairs long they design a
machine that can stitch those fragments
together in programmable ways and
instead of mapping one bit to one base
pair bits are arranged in
multi-dimensional matrices and sets of
molecules represent their location in
each matrix so they're not just
synthesize new DNA for each new piece of
stored information instead they can kind
of like remix the pre fabricated DNA
molecules and so with their innovation
there is separating the process of
synthesizing DNA molecules from the
process of encoding the data
and so it requires less synthesis and
this reduces costs and on June 26th of
this year they announced that they use
this system to store the novel
Hitchhiker's Guide to the galaxy by
Douglas Adams and the poem a road not
taken' by Robert Frost in DNA they plan
to make it commercially available in
2019 so that's kind of like where we're
at today a little bit of what's next
Bitcoin cold storage in DNA there's a
company in August
it's called Carver and August they
announced a way to store Bitcoin
passwords in DNA as a form of cold
storage so keeping passcode separate
from internet connections DNA
cryptography MPEG G which is a standard
for efficiently storing genetic data the
DNA emoji which should be coming to our
phones very soon
enzymatic synthesis basically designing
DNA that's specifically designed for
storage versus like what DNA was
originally designed for which is more
like biological functionality there's
also researchers that designed DNA with
six base pairs instead of four which
again like is an exploration into how
can we store data more efficiently and
compactly in DNA generally like DNA is
pretty much considered just for archival
data storage today but people are
exploring new ways to use it for more
frequent frequent reads and writes DNA
computers there's a whole field that
looks at how you can put boolean
circuits in DNA or create semiconductors
that use enzymatic reactions and so on
and so DNA data storage can be a partner
in all of these projects
there's also hybrid electronic molecular
design which is this kind of interesting
field that's looking at like what can
electronics do best what can molecules
do best and how can we build devices
that combine the two and you know I like
if you think about when we talk about
computing on the edge and the Internet
of Things and Internet of Things devices
like we think about how much computing
can we join the device itself and so
there's kind of a whole field exploring
this in biology as well and so DNA data
storage can be kind of a key part of
that
so in conclusion molecules are the next
frontier when it comes to
miniaturization and more
slaw and the problem is field are going
to be solved in an interdisciplinary way
by combining coding theory information
theory molecular biology synthetic
biology chemistry physical computing
industrial engineering and more and so
that's why it's kind of exciting to
learn about it today by looking at the
world around us we can learn a lot about
efficient algorithms we know there's a
lot of challenges in data storage in
general in the future and DNA might
offer a solution so I encourage you to
follow the field in the next few years
there's going to be a lot of interesting
innovations and a if you're interested
in learning more feel free to come up to
me afterwards
[Applause]